sources tell CBS news that U.S officials
were tracking a potential revolt against
Putin but they were surprised by how
quickly the threat emerged President
Biden returned from Camp David yesterday
after meeting with his top National
Security advisors wija Jang is that the
White House Ouija good morning
Vlad good morning to you and good
morning to everybody the National
Security adviser and the president's
military advisor both canceled overseas
travel plans to attend that emergency
meeting President Biden also spoke with
several world leaders including
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
about the Russian Insurrection the
president instructed American diplomats
to engage with their Russian
counterparts to make sure Moscow
understood its responsibility in
protecting American personnel and
citizens in Russia according to
Secretary of State Anthony blinken
blinken described the uprising as
extraordinary because the conflict was
internal he said it's too soon to say
how it will impact Putin's power but it
does reveal cracks in his Rule now keep
in mind the greatest threat is Russia's
arsenal of nuclear weapons although U.S
officials say moscow's nuclear posture
has not changed Tony we should thank you
very much